i'm a research scientist at the vees
institute and the call the
laboratory of jim collins and today uh
at lab roots here i'd love to talk to
you and and give you our perspective on
our instrument free
crisper based face mask sensor that we
developed for cobin 19 detection
and to give everyone just a little bit
more detail on the context of this
project and how it came to be
i'm going to start with a couple of
slides on the broader project that this
this technology
is kind of in scottsdale
and so
at the collins lab one thing that we're
very interested in we're synthetic
biology lab
and we're always looking for ways to
integrate synthetic biology with other
technologies to kind of bring synthetic
biology out of the lab
and our latest focus has been on trying
to integrate synthetic biology which is
you know we've been working on it for
decades to
try to develop living circuits
essentially kind of a programmable
modularity for biology and integrate
that with this ongoing uh
explosion in
wearable technologies uh where you have
highly portable technologies that allow
for
health monitoring at all times uh and is
highly convenient because you can wear
your sensors uh
with you wherever you go so can we
integrate these two things um you can
kind of imagine
synthetic biology and wearable
technology there's a lot of
incongruities with these two
technologies
and a lot of difficulties in getting
something that you know requires water
uh for living organisms whereas wearable
technology requires convenience and and
the ability to just wear something uh on
your skin
and what we tried to do is actually
integrate those two into kind of one
fundamental technology
and the way we've done that is we have
focused on an area of our lab
where we
have developed freeze-dried synthetic
biology so now these are cell free
synthetic biology reactions
that occur cell free without any living
cells and we've actually freeze dry them
and they're still functionally
intact
and they can be integrated into
different things we have created
paper-based sensors based on them we've
created
a bio manufacturing kits that are
freeze-dried
and here we want to apply that to
wearable synthetic biology
and so we have these freeze-dried
cell-free reactions
this could be cell-free this could be a
crispr based reaction we've also tested
various other kinds of synthetic biology
reactions
to make sure they can be freeze-dried
and we can integrate them into different
materials and when these uh freeze-dried
reactions are rehydrated for example by
a contaminated spill you can imagine if
you're wearing
these freeze-dried reactions
and you get a splash on you um it would
rehydrate the freeze-dried reactions
and activate the circuit um and actually
give you uh some kind of signal based on
synthetic biology biosensors of what's
in in your environment so that was our
our primary focus for the past couple of
years in this particular project for
wearable synthetic biology
one of the prototypes we developed
has fluorescent excitation and emission
fiber optics integrated into layers of
the wearable
unit the modular unit here
that in between these two layers you
have freeze-dried cell-free components
that allow for rehydration and sensing
when you're exposed to something and it
also has
portals that allow that liquid to go
inside and rehydrate their reactions
so here's another view of what it looks
like when you
explode the layers
and the freeze-dried reaction
be it a self-free reaction
or a crispr reaction uh occurs it it's
housed right between these emission and
excitation layers
in between the two fiber optics
and here's a different view where you're
looking in between those two layers
on the top you have an emission layer
which collects
any
photons coming from the sensing layer
and it goes to a
digital sensor and you're looking now at
the very right
you're looking now at the bundle uh this
is a cross section of the fiber optic
bundle and so all of those white dots
that's actually
one fiber optic the one fiber from the i
fiber optic bundle that is
being threaded to a particular zone in
the wearable and you can see at the
bottom
um three of those are fluorescent and
that indicates one particular reaction
zone and on the bottom uh we have an
excitation layer
and that is what actually pumps in the
photons to excite whether or not
there is some kind of fluorescent
reporter that has indicated that you
have been exposed to something and so
this is a prototype we developed and i'm
not going to go into the details of
um how it works because that's that's uh
beyond this presentation
but the prototype does work and we
tested various synthetic biology
biosensors in them
including crispr-based sensors
which is what we want to focus on today
and so you look into
the area right between two of the
optical fibers
again excitation on top
uh an emission on the bottom uh or vice
versa
what you can see is uh we can have
um in the reaction freeze-dried here we
have freeze-dried crispr enzymes
and a fluorescent a quenched fluorophore
uh dna probe in there so in this case
this is a cast 12a
and in the presence of a
for example a viral dna or
viral
nucleic acid or bacterial dna for
example
that gets amplified up by
rt-pcr that we put in
we can actually have that uh
that amplicon be detected by cast 12a
and that activates collateral activity
which cleaves the fluorescent reporter
and then you have fluorescence which is
picked up by your emission uh
fiber optic
piece right there on the bottom
and so in that way we can have a
completely freeze-dried system it has
the amplification part
because we've tested the rt rpa and
we've we've shown that that's
stable in a loftwise form uh it has the
detection part which is a cast 12a
we've also tested cast 13 and that also
works and that is also in freeze drive
form
and so all this is completely stabilized
until it is rehydrated and then it
happens immediately
and we've tested these sensors
on
three different antibiotic resistance
genes so mecca spa
and the herm a
these are antibiotic resistance genes
found in staphylococcus
so pretty relevant for
the clinical infections and we have
found here at the very top of each of
these you see the bundles lighting up
over time so time as we go from left to
right for each of these
um at the bottom images are without
template so you don't have any template
in there you don't have any fluorescence
and you can see right around 45 minutes
to 40 minutes for all of these um you
start to see fluorescents being emitted
through the fiber optic cables and
detected by our electronic sensor um at
the very bottom
right you'll see we're looking at mecha
and that's our lowest concentration that
we tested which was 2.7 femtomolar so
we're getting single digit femtomolar
detection
in a crispr based wearable system that
is completely freeze-dried
and is completely hands-free all you all
that the only thing that really happens
is they get splashed by some kind of
aqueous contaminant that contains dna in
it and that is the only thing that needs
to happen um the rest everything else
happens automatically the detection the
rehydration all of that is automatic
and because it's a crispr
based system it has fantastic
orthogonality you can see here
depending on the trigger and the circuit
that we put in
we have a very uh
sensitive orthogonality that's specific
orthogonality to the gene that we're
sensing here and this this is an example
looking at
three different orthogonal sensors put
into a wearable and splashed with
three different other kinds of
samples containing the gene or not
containing the gene i mean as you see
here on the bottom right
we have a very nice orthogonality and so
at this point
this was around 2020 and
we uh
were in the revision phase for this work
um
and the the pandemic kit
and so our lab had to shut down uh and
while we were shut down
we were brainstorming on how we could
uh contribute to
uh pandemic efforts
based on our technology how could we
apply to the technology
it was a trying time um and we were kind
of stuck at home and we were just
basically zooming each other
and we have several physicians
in our laboratory
that were working in covert wards at
that time and we talked to the the
doctors
um and uh what they
mentioned once we presented this to them
was if we could find a way
to do on-site
wearable testing
of copen19
and uh
their their their kind of thought behind
this was
well right now we're in the coveted
wards things are absolutely slammed
and it's taking
over 24 hours just to get uh pcr rtpcr
diagnostics
um to get the results back to these
patients in order to triage them because
you have to know whether or not they
were covered 19 positive in order to
actually put them in the ward um and so
they were like if you could integrate
this with some kind of wearable so where
the doctors don't have to
actually do a lot of the
swabbing and send it off the lab and
then wait for it and just have the
actual
point of care diagnosis happen right
there for the patient that would be
fantastic
and so that's what we worked on um and
so
one thing that we wanted to look at was
is it possible to do
nucleic acid amplification
at the point of care
with minimal instrumentation
and
you know this was around february uh
when the the
the uh
the pandemic was spreading around the
world and in april this is what
uh dr deborah burks the white house
coronavirus response coordinator said
and she quote and i quote there will
never be the ability on a nucleic acid
test to do 300 million tests a day or to
test everyone before they go to work
or school
right and so you know that's very
accurate at that time there really
wasn't any way to do quick nucleic acid
tests
for anyone that wanted it
at home
before you go to work or you know go to
school whenever you wanted on demand
nucleic acid testing was not available
and today it still really isn't
available
and so that's what i'm going to go
on to next
and
so what we developed was we developed a
nucleic acid diagnostic based on crispr
uh detection
for cover 19 that's integrated into a
face mask
so really quickly i'm going to go
through some of the
the key
aspects of our
face mask sensor so it can kind of
ground you into why this technology is
unique and why it's needed
one thing it's sensitive
based on the data that i'm going to show
you we can show that it's comparable
to rt pcr results so the same results
you would that would you would require a
laboratory to perform you can actually
have it completely integrated onto face
mask with our sensor and it's as
sensitive as the who approved rt pcr
assays
also
it's very simplified
as i mentioned there's no laboratory
needed there's actually no instrument
needed there's no electronics there's no
power source
everything is passively driven and
there's there's absolutely no
instrumentation at all and that we think
that's a huge advantage
compared to everything else that is out
there
today
another thing is that it is a complete
point of care solution
so from sample collection it actually
collects a sample
and everything is actually integrated
onto including the analysis so
from
output and result takes only 90 minutes
and that's roughly 45 minutes to 90
minutes that's that's the range of our
our uh the execution of our sensor i
mean the only thing it takes is the
press of a button so that's the only
thing the user requires uh the user
intervention is required is the press of
a button
the sensor is very lightweight you can
hardly notice it it's about one gram
again uh all of the reactions are freeze
dried so it's shelf stable you can
actually store this at room temperature
it's stable
at room temperature um and it the
operation is also completely at room
temperature um therefore you don't
really need any heating to actually make
the reactions uh occur
it's programmable because it's crisper
based you can easily reprogram it to
detect different variants
and
last thing but very important
is that it's inexpensive the add-on cost
of one of these sensors
for a face mask is only five dollars so
that's you know the cup of a fancy
starbucks
latte and and you have a cobia 19
sensor diagnostic that is
completely integrated into your face
mask
and so the idea behind this is you know
if people are already wearing masks in
the middle of a pandemic
we can just
easily add on
a diagnostic to it so while you're
wearing it you're actually collecting
the sample and and it's collecting the
sample from your breath
when you're breathing when you're
talking when you're coughing when you're
sneezing
um and it collects on the sample pad on
the very the inside of the mask
and at the end of the day or or whenever
you uh have collected enough sample you
press the button and it runs the deliver
the analysis to see whether or not you
have kobit 19.
and so this is one of our early early
prototypes um so we're looking at
on the outside what it looks like on the
outside you only have a button and an
indicator
so that the output indicator is a ladder
flow asset strip
on the inside you see all the different
components of our sensor
so our sensor is one unit
it's continuous but it's composed of
four different pieces you have a water
reservoir which contains your water
you have a sample collection zone and
that is a pad that actually collects
breath samples
then you have the
micro pad and that is that houses all
the freeze-dried reactions in a
three-dimensional
paper-based device and then finally that
is connected to lab flow assay which
leads to the outside so that you can see
the result and the lateral flow assay
strip is what gives you the visual
indicator
and so now let's uh
let's run through
what actually happens when you're
wearing the mask and we'll go through
this as uh observed from the inside of
the mask
um
and so if you look on the inside of the
mask the first thing that happens is
sample collection
and we estimate that you'll need about
15 to 20 minutes of wearing this at the
minimum
to collect enough sample
for the detection to occur
and obviously
if you wore it for a longer time
the the results would be much better
because you would be collecting more and
more sample
and so we we do anticipate if this was
to be
produced that we would probably
recommend
wearing the mask for an hour to get
accurate accurate results
so the first thing is sample collection
the patient wears the mask the user
wears the mask
and it clicks on the sample pad which
you can see there
the red dots are indicative of
viral particles for example
and the next step is when you're ready
you activate the sensor and that simply
is the press of a button the button
that's on the outside of the mask in
different versions we actually flip the
the
the water reservoir so it's also on the
outside
but what the pressing the button does is
it connects the water in the reservoir
to the rest of the sensor and so now
that water which was
previously
completely uh
separated from the rest of the system it
actually
connects that and so it allows water to
flow into the system by the press of
that button
and we've also shown that when you do
that you actually do get concentration
uh
of particles in the sample front and i
have some slides to show you that with
some some sample dye for example
and so the sample
gets pushed through the sample pad
and into the micro pad
which is the next layer and that
contains all the different reactions
i'll go throughout that in some more
detail but we have three different
reactions occurring in the micropad a
lysis reaction
an amplification reaction
and then the cast 12a crispr base
detection reaction
when that reaction
is completed
it flows into the ladder flow assay
which gives you a visual readout and the
time between
uh activating the sensor pressing the
button
and getting an actual visual readout we
found it varies between 45 to 90 minutes
and you might think well that's a pretty
large variation there in execution time
and that's because every single sensor
we used
in this study was handmade so everything
was uh you know hand cut
not hand cut but we also we used laser
cutting but everything was assembled by
hand everything was you know
freeze-dried manually and so there was a
lot of error that goes into that
which is something that we're hoping to
to rectify uh in the future
and if we look at
breaking down
that sensor again into its constituent
parts
you have quad reservoir here which is
basically a blister pack containing the
water
sample collection area this is what
collects everything it's a porous uh
substrate that we found that we had
screened for to find
uh something that would
allow lateral flow
and collect sample at the same time
here's a micropad you can see it's kind
of folded in an accordion shape and each
of those spots in the middle are where
the reaction is housed
and then finally your ladder flow assay
output
uh lateral flow output and this was a
commercial lateral flow assay from
millennia biotech that we used
um and here's showing you some of the
the sample flow through the sensor
here on the left we spotted uh just
die blue dye on the sample collection
pad
and then we press the button to allow
the water to flow through the sample pad
and as you can see the
the the dye concentrates at the
rehydration front very similar to what
would happen if you're doing a
paper chromatography for example
um and then it flows directly into the
micropad and that all occurs within you
know six minutes so it's relatively fast
and once it's in the micropad
what you have is you have
three different zones as i mentioned
before a license zone an amplification
which is rtrpa
and then a
cast 12a detection zone
at the end and in between each of these
reactions we have a time delay
the time delay is consist consists of a
molten
and dried
polyvinyl alcohol and these have been
optimized to allow for a time delay of
between 10 to 15 minutes
so the sample sits and hydrates each of
these reactions consecutively for 10 to
15 minutes before moving on to the next
one
and in that way we can actually control
the amount of time
and where the rehydration front is
as it progresses through the sensor
um and to look at some some more detail
into what's going on in the reactions um
so the lysis reaction contains
um detergents that we we combed the
literature we looked at copic 19
uh biophysical papers where they they
had to isolate components of coping 19.
and there's a lot of a wealth of
information on what methods people use
to extract different proteins and and
extract the nucleic acid as well
and we made a list of all of the the
detergent combinations that people have
used
and we screened those to look for ones
that were compatible with our system
that is it has to be freeze dried
and the detergent can't actually
dissolve our micro pad so the micro pad
has
wax layers on it to kind of
prevent everything from flowing outside
of the micropad
and some of the detergents actually
dissolve this wax layer
and so we narrowed it down to slices
components that were efficient
based on literature of lysing the
coronavirus
um
and seemed to work in our system as a
freeze-dried component
then the isothermal amplification this
was actually
a significant part of our
optimization is getting the isothermal
amplification that is the rtrpa
to work at room temperature so all of
this all of these reactions
are hydrated and work at completely
ambient temperatures
and that's something that i really want
to stress it's a huge
advantage of our system compared to
other systems that require heating in
order to work
so after you press that button there's
no other user intervention needed
the flow is driven by capillary action
and everything happens at room
temperature
and the third reaction is a cast 12a
sherlock detection reaction which uses
a fam biotin single-stranded dna probe
so any collateral activity from the cast
12a
as it recognizes
the amplicon from the second
reaction stage
gets translated into a cleavage of that
probe that cleavage is actually detected
in
the lateral flow assay shown on the
right here
so
if you have a negative
covid result
you have two bands and with a strong
positive result you have only one band
show up which is your t-band or your
test band
and what we're actually targeting using
the rt rpa primers
is the spike gene and
the coba gene
in the covid
virus and
we targeted the area of the spike gene
this was back in
2020 of the summer 2020
that we suspected
would most likely
have a lot of mutations this is the the
docking area in the spike gene
um and you know as time has kind of
proven we were actually right so within
our amplicon region here
a lot of these variant mutations uh do
actually occur in that that region
and so uh we could swap out the the grna
for
the
cast 12a to actually target those
different variants and actually give us
a variant
based face mask diagnostic if we wanted
so the diagram shows our primers
uh rt rpa primers as well as in red
where the grna is targeting the amplicon
and at the very end this is what the
lateral flow assay output looks like
it's actually
uh
position oriented so that you have to
bend it backwards
so that it's hidden from public view but
the clinician if if a clinician wants to
see the results all they do is bend the
strip back
or if this is done at home
the the user just has to take the mask
off and bend the strip back once it's
done
all right so
in terms of testing for the sensitivity
these were bench top tests where we
added contrived samples onto the sample
pad
so these were
rna
templates
of covert 19 genomic rna
specifically the spike gene that were
added onto the sample pad
at different numbers copies of target
and what you can see here is that we can
detect it down to
uh
you know 500 copies of target and on the
the
right hand side
you see these are those are
representative ladder flow asset output
uh images that we're showing here and so
down to two orders of magnitude copies
of target
and again each of these the data points
shown in these graphs
is a completely
separate
uh face mask sensor that was fabricated
and assembled
and for hand assembling a lot of these
we think the
the variability in the results is
actually quite good
um and so based on this level of
sensitivity
it's roughly in line with the who
approved rtpcr assays and what you can
expect for the sensitivity of those
next we wanted to look at specificity so
how specific is it for
uh soros kobe 2.
and no surprise there because this is a
crispr based method
and you know it's very highly sensitive
so we tested this against uh spike jeans
that were
uh taken from different
circulating human coronaviruses
so there are four different uh
circulating hemorrhage coronaviruses
that we tested against
and as you can see for all of these um
they're at a very low detection level
whereas with stars kobe 2 we get a very
great a nice positive result there and
as you can see you can see
on the right hand side again
representatives representative images of
the ladder flow assays
from each of the groups that we tested
so at this point
we did much of the testing in vitro this
was early on in the pandemic
early summer
um and the reviewers came back and you
know they wanted us to do to be a bit
more uh
kind of robust in our analysis and they
asked for
whether or not we could do either on
patients or a aerosolized virus
and those were the two things that we
were asked to do
um so the
during that time we didn't think uh just
due to the logistics of where we were we
were in the middle of the summer spike
doing a
clinical trial getting it approved
through the university was just
uh not within the timeline that the
reviewers gave us
and so we looked for the option of uh
aerosolizing the virus and to do that
it took us uh over a month but we
cobbled together
uh a breathing simulator
that was based on
some very kind
loaner equipment from industry where you
have a spontaneous breathing generator
this generates breathing cadence the
right title volume everything very very
accurately
simulating human breathing
we pump that through a system where we
have an inline aerosol production so we
nebulize
um
mrna
uh
target here and so rna is getting
aerosolized through a nebulizer that
goes through a heat sleeve
and then that gets routed through an
anatomically precise airway mannequin so
that it it
simulates the structure
of
the human respiratory system
um
and
the next slide you can see
here this is our reservoir for the
nebulizer where we're actually pipetting
in our sample so this again this is a
spike gene rna that's being propelled in
here
and the aerosols that are generated
using this nebulizer
the aerosols have roughly the same uh
diameter as
small aerosols generated by uh human
breathing so
you know less than five microns
and
here is the rest of the simulator shown
here
i have to
really thank our sponsors
for
loaning us the equipment the test chest
lung simulator
as well as the two sigma
high fidelity airway simulator here
and so that was our system that we used
to simulate
the
um
breathing and aerosolization of
rna
for testing our mask
and with this
um the sample flows through that path
gets aerosolized then finally makes its
way to the mannequin
and based on
our simulator
we did sensitivity testing
and showed that we
did get we basically had the same level
of sensitivity
that we found for the in vitro testing
we did earlier so we get very similar uh
sensitivities where
um
we get a test
to
control ratio
um for copies of target that are on the
order of like millions of copies which
is what we tested using our mannequin
system
um and so that's kind of where we
stopped with that and
um
this is published now this is published
in nature biotechnology just published a
few months ago um and at this point we
are
let's go ahead and go through the
conclusions for some of this
so what are the
conclusions for uh some of this work
well one thing is we've demonstrated
a proof of concept
for an instrument-free
rtrpa cast 12-way sensor
for sars kobe 2 detection and this is
completely in breath samples
it's highly convenient because it is
detecting the patient's breath and also
um it requires no instrumentation uh
which is you know that's we think that's
a huge
uh unique
aspect of this particular technology
that it doesn't require any electronics
at all
it's completely passively driven
so everything occurs at room temperature
um the storage occurs at room
temperature so you don't have to rely on
a cold chain to get this to where it
needs to be you can you can ship this
completely at room temperature
and the operation also occurs at room
temperatures so that again obviates a
need for electronics
the third thing that their conclusion is
that we have been able to reduce the
operational complexity
of covet 19 testing
so typically you would have to go
somewhere get a nasopharyngeal swab
the
that would they would have to stick it
into a test tube it would have to get
milled to a laboratory
they would laboratory would have to
batch
a bunch of different reactions together
kind of do the sample prep you know a
lot of hands-on technician
liquid handling at that point
um gets put into some machine to detect
it
and
all that we have reduced down to just
one action the press of a button on a
mask
you press a button and you get the same
level of sensitivity for an arc as you
would for an rtpcr result
that
requires all of those steps
and
there's a huge
um
uh component here where we can actually
take this technology and potentially
have a face mask
sars kobe 2 diagnostic
which where you can actually test every
man woman and child
before they go to work or before they go
to school
in a relatively inexpensive manner
and so what are the next things that we
need to do for this technology well one
thing is we need to to work on the
design optimization uh these were just
prototypes that we tested
um to just show proof of concept
and we do know there are lots of levels
of failure uh based on uh the way that
we've we
have assembled and designed this and and
none of these uh um are
that's all of the the modes of failure
that we've identified are easily
adjustable
uh by redesign of our sensor and usually
they occur in the assembly
of how we assemble the different
components and
how the different components match
together
and we think a lot of that will be
solved uh in the next phase which is the
design for manufacturability
so how do we take this cover 19 face
mask that is crisper based
and take it from something that we
assembled by hand so we had a number of
people in lab just sitting there
assembling each of these by hand how do
we take that from where it's at right
now into something that can be mass
manufactured using high throughput
machinery
and that would greatly reduce the
variability
in the assembly process that leads to
some of those design failures that i
mentioned before uh assembly failures
that is that i mentioned before
um and last but not least one thing that
i definitely want to point out and and
mention here
is that
the
all the the the results all the data
that we're showing here were not
performed on human patients um and so
that's something that needs to be
pointed out
and that's something we really need to
do is take this
the system which we have
this proof of concept for contrived
samples and actually move this into
clinical studies and to to demonstrate
how this would work uh on clinical
patients breathing live bars into the
mask
and also that would give us an
indication onto the user design as well
because you can imagine
wearing a mask and having it collect
sample
and
running a diagnostic in the mask itself
would pose some unique challenges for
a user
operation so
would we you know execute the
the sensor detection while the patient
is wearing it or is it better to take
the mask off and uh
execute the the sensor
on the on the table for example so these
are things that we have to um
go through when we
go through clinical studies
and that's something that we are
actually
uh partnering we're trying to partner
with a number of people to get us
through all of these
these challenges right now in terms of
the divine optimization the the
manufacturability uh and and setting up
for uh future clinical studies as well
um so with that i'll open it for any uh
questions that you might have um
and
i'd like to thank the the entire team
this was definitely a team effort
so luis uh sewingson was a co-first
author on this work with me
um and we had a number of great people
at the v's uh and of course our our pi
jim collins professor jim collins was
the one that really kind of pushed this
um
this uh
work to
be developed during
these trying times and
on the right you have all of our uh
funding
uh and
our sponsors for this um and on the
middle you have a qr link to our nature
biotech paper please check it out uh it
contains all the wearables
and all of the uh covet 19 face mask
diagnostics data that you see here as
well you can read about it in more
detail
thank you